they have these social norms around
productivity right now right do more and
less time like how many books are there
out there that tell you like you know
how many more things you can squeeze
into a day and how to be Uber productive
and so we have an unspoken cultural norm
that if you're a productive person
you're a good person if you're not a
productive person you're a bad person by
definition there is no such thing as
good procrastination procrastination can
never be a good thing because there's
always harmful consequences attached to
we don't procrastinate because we have
no sense of time we don't procrastinate
because we're lazy it's going to the
source and saying what is the reason we
don't procrastinate on things that are
fun you know the feeling of being a bad
person because you're not productive
that's what happens when you
procrastinate I feel ashamed and I'm
procrastinating and so it makes it
difficult to reach out and talk to
people and say I don't really know what
to do here can you lay this task out for
me especially if you've already started
to procrastinate but that is the best
thing to do